sí
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález
europa está contra la pared y más
presionada que nunca frente a uno de sus
antiguos y complejos problemas el
suministro de gas el suministro de
petróleo y la dependencia energética de
rusia país del que provee procede cerca
del 40 por ciento de la demanda de gas
de la unión europea el gas extraído en
el centro y en el norte de rusia
representa cerca de la totalidad del gas
que consume en estonia letonia lituania
suecia y finlandia también corresponde a
la mitad del suministro de polonia la
república checa eslovaquia austria y
cerca del 40% del consumo de alemania el
motor económico de la unión europea son
múltiples los gasoductos que llevan gas
desde el territorio ruso desde el norte
y el centro del país hasta diferentes
puntos de europa el más reciente es este
que ven arriba el llamado norte stream
que llevaría gas desde el norte de rusia
desde la ciudad de víborg en el golfo de
finlandia a través del mar báltico hasta
greifswald en el norte de alemania y de
ahí sería repartido para el resto del
continente
europeo este nunca fue puesto en marcha
por las sanciones de eeuu a rusia una
segunda línea viene desde el centro de
rusia a través de moscú minsk en belarús
pasaría por polonia hasta berlín en
alemania y de allí también sería
distribuido al resto de europa la
tercera línea que fue hasta hace
relativamente poco la línea más
importante viene desde la ciudad de
petrov un poco más al sur de moscú pasa
a hardcore o hard keep en ucrania cruza
kyev cruza todo el territorio ucraniano
de este a oeste entra viena y de allí va
hasta el puerto de rotterdam en los
países bajos una cuarta línea también
parte desde la ciudad de petrov pero
ésta sale hacia el sur de ucrania y
llega hasta la ciudad de burgas a través
de esta costa y también hay una vía
alterna a través del mar en negro hay un
proyecto para extenderlo a partir de
bulgaria hacia los países de los
balcanes y una última línea también
parte desde la ciudad de bakú en
azerbaiyán a través de territorio ruso
cruza el mar negro y entra a territorio
turco y desde allí se distribuye también
a través de tuberías turcas hacia el sur
de europa
y otros socios tienen la unión europea'
entonces para abastecerse de gas en caso
de que deje de lado todas estas
conexiones con rusia el segundo mayor
exportador de gas a la unión europea es
noruega es representa cerca de un tercio
del suministro total es un muy poco si
se compara con rusia pero desde sus
enormes yacimientos en el mar del norte
en el norte de europa allí se extrae gas
que luego se envía hasta el reino unido-
pasando por la ciudad de aberdeen en el
norte de escocia a londres y de allí
pasa hasta la ciudad de rotterdam en los
países bajos también hay una línea
directa desde aberdeen hasta perdón
desde el mar del norte hasta los países
bajos y alemania desde donde se
distribuye también a otros países hay un
tercer proveedor muy importante argelia
acá en el norte de áfrica que lleva gas
hasta españa hasta italia y hasta
francia y también en parte de portugal
recibe gas desde allí hay una línea que
va desde estos territorios del norte de
argelia a través de tánger en marruecos
a córdoba en españa' y de allí sale
hasta parís o hasta lisboa portugal hay
otras líneas que bastan
almería también en el sur de españa y
finalmente hay dos gasoductos que
suministran gas a través de cerdeña y a
través de la isla de sicilia al
territorio italiano que es desde donde
también se suministra luego gas a otros
países del centro de europa
hay unos gasoductos un poco más
sencillos una infraestructura un poco
más sencilla que viene desde los
territorios de azerbaiyán desde donde se
extraen allí en bakú en la capital van
hasta a tbilisi la capital de georgia y
entran al territorio turco y cruzan
directo hasta albania también abarcando
un poco algunos de los países de los
balcanes la preocupación en bruselas y
entre los 27 países es sobre la
situación energética es grande allí los
países no se han podido poner de acuerdo
porque hay diferentes grados de
dependencia sobre el gas ruso por eso
algunos de los mandatarios presidentes y
también delegados o funcionarios de los
países de la unión europea han hecho un
llamado a volver las políticas un poco
más rápidas y ponerlas en marcha cuanto
antes por lo menos así lo dijo la
ministra de exteriores de alemania estas
fueron sus palabras
y sabemos que las dependencias
energéticas de los 27 estados miembros
de la unión europea varían
mainz si realmente queremos lograr algo
juntos como unión europea necesitamos un
calendario europeo común sobre cómo
eliminar por completo las importaciones
de energía fósil de rusia esto es lo que
ya deberíamos haber hecho después de
y por supuesto rusia también se ha
manifestado en torno a esta crisis
energética que se está desatando en
europa y el posible cierre de este
suministro de gas ruso a todo el
territorio de la unión europea el
presidente ruso vladimir putin también
se refirió a este tema escuchemos
la situación en el sector de la energía
está empeorando como resultado de
medidas no comerciales y contundentes
incluida la presión administrativa sobre
nuestra empresa gazprom en algunos
países europeos registran y
observamos que nuestros socios una vez
más están tratando de desviar la
responsabilidad de su propio error al
campo de la economía y la energía a
rusia y resolver problemas causados por
ellos y de nuevo a nuestras cosas más
aquí hay una solución
bueno pues para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a rosa net y barrios analista
independiente de energía y consejería
fundadora de voz experta y ya se
encuentra en la ciudad de mexico en la
capital mexicana también se une a esta
conversación jorge piñón él es director
del programa para latinoamérica y el
caribe del centro internacional de
energía y política ambiental de la
universidad de texas él se encuentra
precisamente en la ciudad de austin en
el sur de texas y van a estar con
nosotros en este programa ustedes
también pueden estar con nosotros a
través de las redes sociales ustedes
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas al respecto lo pueden hacerles
recuerdo estamos en facebook en
instagram también estamos en twitter nos
encuentran como france24
y arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal el numeral o la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 dejen todos sus
preguntas para conversar sobre este tema
nos interesa mucho conocer su opinión
comenzó entonces con rózsa net y le doy
la bienvenida al programa bienvenida a
rosa net y gracias por estar con
nosotros y comienzo por preguntarle como
punto de partida de este debate qué tan
unida está la unión europea en cuanto a
dejar de depender totalmente del gas
ruso y del carbón ruso y de otros
hidrocarburos para buscar energías
alternas o países que los puedan
suministrar de manera alterna claro pues
mira yo creo que hay una hay una serie
de indicadores que dan respuesta a tu
pregunta antes que nada muchísimas
gracias por la invitación y encantada de
compartir la mesa con jorge regresando
entonces al tema ahí el el suministro de
gas petróleo carbón de rusia hacia
europa no se ha suspendido y no se ha
suspendido porque simple y sencillamente
no hay forma de sustituirlo de manera
inmediata sin detener a la economía y
luego que todo esto implicaría tenemos
situaciones tan complejas como un
reporte ya de los inventarios de gas más
o menos sobre el 27 por ciento de la
capacidad total y esto implica que ya
están los inventarios por debajo de los
promedios de los últimos cinco años
otro elemento importante es bueno
definitivamente en el gobierno del
presidente vaivén firma con la unión
europea un acuerdo una determina buscar
en la sustitución de gas ruso con un
suministro de los eeuu sin embargo
insisto el el problema es que se
requiere tiempo no es absolutamente
imposible
para cualquier país incluso para el que
se encuentre mejor
interconectado que tenga listas las
instalaciones para recibir ese gas que
provenga de otro lado ahorita platicamos
de otros detalles digamos nada menores
para considerar lo que impide
tomar este acuerdo definitivo y decir
pues adelante vamos a sustituirlo es
decir me parece a mí que hay esta guerra
esta situación tan compleja que estamos
viviendo en el mundo deja muy claro que
no hay dudas sobre la transición
energética pero no estamos en
condiciones y jorge cuál es su opinión
qué tan unida está entonces la unión
europea en cuanto a esta decisión que ya
vemos hay diferencias por lo menos en
cuanto a la dependencia del gas ruso
unos países dependen más que otros esto
que tanto va a dificultar ese proceso de
rompimiento
y esa toma de decisiones para buscar
energías alternativas para poner en
marcha planes o para buscar países que
suministren y reemplacen el suministro
ruso
gracias santiago y saludos a la rosa net
y como ella dijo esta es una situación
muy difícil que ambos bandos van a tener
dificultad en cerrar el grifo en su
totalidad para rusia le va a ser muy muy
difícil encontrar otros mercados para su
gas natural ya que esas líneas de
transmisión van de este a oeste así que
es imposible por ejemplo los gasoductos
que van a la china ya está en la
capacidad así que sería un difícil
problema para rusia buscar nuevos
mercados para ese gas natural con la
única opción de cerrar entonces los
yacimientos el mismo problema tiene
europa que puede causar un alza en los
precios del petróleo y yo creo que es
alemania quien en realidad se está
oponiendo a este tipo de estrategia ya
que pudiera llevar a la región a una
recesión por el alza de los precios del
petróleo y del y del gas natural los
esteros europa tiene hoy en día 25
terminales
regasificación de gas natural gas
natural licuado así que por lo menos hay
una alternativa que quizás los eeuu
puedan los eeuu puede suministrar parte
de ese déficit ruso pero no en su
totalidad si hay 10 terminales en el
mediterráneo' 8 en el norte en el mar
norte 2 en el báltico hay 5 en la zona
del atlántico así que terminales para
recibir el gas natural licuado en
terminales de regasificación si las
tienen el problema ahí es el cuello de
botella en el almacenamiento y también
como dije y como tú explicaste muy bien
los gasoductos van de este a oeste no de
oeste al este
rózsa net y dijo que esto va a tomar
tiempo las alternativas para estos estos
tipos de modelos de problemática de
logística si no son fáciles de aclarar
usted habla de terminales de
gasificación y una puesta en marcha
recientemente está frente a las costas
del puerto de klaipeda en las costas de
lituania en el báltico que usted lo
mencionaba esto le permitió a esta
república báltica cortar por completo el
suministro de gas procedente de la
federación de rusia era un país que
dependía 100% del suministro de gas
desde moscú este es el primer país de la
unión europea en dar este paso es un
ejemplo a seguir es un ejemplo que
pueden seguir otros estados pequeños no
digamos alemania con más de 80 millones
de habitantes pero otros países un poco
más pequeños que tengan la capacidad de
hacer algo similar puede ser un primer
paso como lo vio ustedes jorge si hay
países yo creo que no va a suceder en su
totalidad que la unión europea va a
tomar esa decisión en común tienes a
españa por ejemplo españa tiene seis
diferentes terminales para la
regasificación de gas natural hay
capacidad todavía en la línea que
atraviesa marruecos aunque argelia no
tiene más capacidad de producción si hay
capacidad de enviar gas natural así que
españa quizás esté en esa posición pero
dudo que ellos unilateralmente
en esa decisión hay algunos países que
sí lo podrían hacer pero yo dudo que
ellos solos lo harán en el futuro rózsa
net y este momento de esta coyuntura
internacional el momento en el que se
encuentra europa con una guerra en el
este de su territorio en el este del
continente es momento para que este
continente y específicamente la unión
europea adopte lo que se llama una
energía muleta
o de transición o de simplemente ya un
salto hacia un nuevo tipo de energías o
a la adopción total de energías
renovables o es simplemente para
acelerar la transición usted cómo lo ve
a ver un paso atrás cuando en los
setentas vivimos sin embargo árabe el
embargo petrolero árabe el mundo entero
tomó una serie de decisiones que
afectaron los siguientes 50 años del
planeta me parece que estamos ante un
ante una situación muy similar por
razones distintas pues en este caso de
decisión de no tomar esa el volumen de
digamos que está presionando los precios
en este momento dicho eso
[Música]
insisto creo que está muy claro que hay
que llegar a la transición energética
pero también me parece
desafortunadamente está muy claro que no
se puede hacer de la noche a la mañana
particularmente en temas de gas natural
voy a tomar un poco sobre la pregunta
que mencionabas hacer hace un momento me
parece que una de las recomendaciones
eventualmente de cebada se van a tener
que evaluar para efectos de seguridad
energética en materia de gas natural es
tener vamos a decirlo así una serie de
preparaciones listas en las costas para
recibir barcos directamente es decir
tener plantas flotantes posibilidad de
recibir plantas flotantes que finalmente
si bien son inversiones que elevan el
costo de la operación de los sistemas
energéticos también es cierto que no te
amarran a una instalación fija que lleva
tiempo etcétera etcétera entonces creo
que ahora sí tratando de empatar lo que
estoy diciendo con tu pregunta es me
parece que no es posible para la
humanidad simple y sencillamente soltar
los hidrocarburos debe en particular gas
natural y porque además está toda la
cadena química alimentos etcétera y
llegar directamente a la transición la
transición entonces para mí
definitivamente va a tener que ser mucho
más paulatina de lo que habíamos pensado
pero no soltar lo
importante de esa aclaración incluso en
bruselas la unión europea ha dicho que
este rompimiento del suministro del gas
procedente de rusia puede darse por
completo alrededor del 2027 de aquí a
eso puede que ya haya sido solucionado
el conflicto esta invasión rusa y
ucrania puede que haya restablecido las
relaciones entre bruselas y moscú y se
haya restablecido y normalizado el
suministro no sabemos que pueda pasar de
aquí a los siguientes cinco años que
tenemos por delante pero pero lo que es
claro es que europa está decidida a no
tener que depender de ese gas procedente
de los pozos del centro de siberia y del
norte de rusia y ahí es donde entra un
actor muy importante y es eeuu porque
usted lo mencionaba en su intervención
anterior
eeuu
el primero que salió alzar la mano a
decir tranquilos yo les puedo
suministrar gas les puedo suministrar
petróleo que tanto tiene aquí un poco de
conspiración política que eeuu estaba
esperando un escenario así para entrar a
actuar o que simplemente es una
oportunidad que se le está presentando
que análisis hace usted
bueno yo que otros de eeuu tiene la
capacidad desde el punto de vista de su
producción su nivel de producción de
gran natural así como las líneas de
transmisión y los gasoductos que llevan
ese gas a la costa del golfo de méxico
que es donde están las plantas de
licuefacción el problema es que no
tenemos suficiente capacidad de luque
facción aunque tenemos entre 4 y 6
proyectos que están en camino que en los
próximos dos o tres años se van a
terminar por cierto para el próximo año
se espera que los estados unidos superen
australia y acatar con el mayor
exportador de gas natural gas natural
licuado pero también tenemos el problema
que muchas de estas plantas ya tienen
sus contratos es decir estos estas
plantas se construyen con contratos a
largo plazo tienen un cliente ya sea
corea-japón que van a comprar gas por
15-20 años así que es muy difícil
también cambiar esos contratos para la
hora abastecer a un nuevo cliente aunque
se está se está haciendo pero a hero
cuello de botella lo tenemos en europa
los estados unidos quizás el cálculo
nuestro es que podamos suministrar
alrededor del 60 por ciento del déficit
de la pérdida total del gas ruso pero
solamente el 60 por ciento pero como
dijo zanetti y todo esto va a tomar
tiempo es decir no hay ninguna solución
a corto plazo europa tiene que hacer su
parte es decir construir las plantas ya
sean flotantes o no para regasificación
y nosotros tenemos que ampliar la
capacidad para exportar gas natural
licuado por cierto se australia y qatar
también van a ser dos importantes socios
importantes socios y son importantes
proveedores a nivel internacional de
usted no mencionaba jorge rosa necesita
le doy la palabra quiero hacerle esta
pregunta a jorge porque va ligada con el
tema de eeuu y es en washington se le
criticó mucho por poner y usted va a
decir si está de acuerdo no por poner
bajo presión a alemania y europa
al no permitirle abrir el gasoducto del
norte string precisamente por las
sanciones que ya habían impuestas a
rusia esto significó un
apretar a la unión europea en cuanto al
suministro y cerrarle una válvula de
suministro muy importante a través del
báltico eeuu allí estaba apretando
sabiendo lo que esto le podía beneficiar
más allá de las intenciones políticas
estaban en juego los habitantes de la
unión europea-27 países sin gas
bueno esta administración tiene un reto
muy importante y son las elecciones del
mes de noviembre que es posible que
pierdan la mayoría en el congreso y eso
los está llevando a tomar ciertas
decisiones políticas que quizás tengan
menos sentido común por ejemplo nuestra
relación con el canadá el cual
suministra hoy a este país con más del
50 por ciento de las importaciones
nuestras importaciones de petróleo crudo
así que esta administración ha tomado
ciertos pasos que para mí han sido un
error pero también europa europa decidió
poner todos sus huevos en una sola
canasta y eso fue un grave error decidió
cerrar ciertas plantas nucleares
encerrar termoeléctricas de carbón es
decir tomó una posición una vez más
repito en que puso todos los huevos en
una misma canasta que para cualquier
país del mundo es un error lo importante
es tener diversidad
energética desde el punto de vista de
diferentes
de producción de energía y también de
diferentes países para suministrar los
combustibles para esas plantas de
energía claro lo que le queda claro es
esta lección que recibe la unión europea
porque no es la primera vez que tiene
problemas con rusia para garantizar este
suministro de gas rosa net y hablemos
entonces de las posibilidades que tienen
en europa para diversificar para buscar
nuevos proveedores y también para ver
cómo van a modernizar o elaborar o
construir plantas esto qué significa
porque las capacidades de los países son
diferentes no podemos hablar de un país
como alemania que es la potencia
económica de la unión europea que tiene
la capacidad de empezar un proyecto
rápidamente a otros países como por
ejemplo eslovenia hungría o la república
checa o eslovaquia que tienen menos
capacidad económica esto entonces lo
vamos a ver traducido en aumento de
impuestos
e impuestos sobre la energía
unas leyes mucho más estrictas en cuanto
a la parte de suministros de energía
simplemente para poder financiar estos
nuevos proyectos que lleven a la
transición
pues mira hay un pendiente digamos que
tienen las potencias mundiales con
relación al financiamiento para la
transición pasamos sus 100 mil millones
de dólares anuales que tendrían que
haber estado poniendo en la mesa
justamente para acelerar la transición
esa esa es un compromiso que no se ha
cumplido y que en este momento resulta
más claro que nunca que es necesario el
adoptar en este momento medidas que
encarecen la vida de los de la sociedad
me parece que ningún gobierno del mundo
lo va a hacer de hecho lo que estamos
viendo son estas veces pero esta medida
desesperada de establecer subsidios para
el consumo de combustibles está
ocurriendo en todo el mundo también está
corriendo méxico pero vamos lo pongo
como el contraste es muy difícil pensar
que la decisión adecuada por más que
económicamente todos sepamos que el
precio es una señal muy clara para
reducir la demanda me parece muy
complicado desde el punto de vista
político adoptar esas medidas y sin duda
es un reto que pasa por la
composición del mercado al final no hay
que olvidar a europa compite con asia en
términos de
de ser un comprador importante de
energía pues de ser un importador neto
de energía entonces esa es una realidad
sigue tec distingue todavía más la
posibilidad de encarecer para tránsito
para transitar hacia asia ar o inicia
limpia res janet y que hay de la
posibilidad de tener un mercado común de
energía y unas leyes comunes en la unión
europea aquí lo que vemos es que cada
país tomará sus decisiones lituania ya
cortó por lo sano el suministro ruso hay
países que dicen no lo podemos hacer por
ejemplo bulgaria depende energéticamente
100% de la energía y del gas y el carbón
que viene de rusia
si hay una política común si hay un
mercado común si el bloque entero compra
en conjunto y no país por país esto
podría facilitar
la distribución tal vez
vamos me parece que
la fuerza del volumen es es indiscutible
pues en la medida que tienes un solo
comprador y lo tengo que decir así un
solo vendedor me explico la fuerza del
volumen es importante sin embargo
es muy difícil empatar los intereses de
países con diferentes grados de
desarrollo con diferentes
características físicas es decir lo más
que ha aprobado la unión europea pues
que ha podido hacer han sido directivas
generales pero habiendo dejado una gran
margen para la capacidad de decisión de
cada país insisto aquí hay un tema
político que me parece extremadamente
difícil de resolver y no quiero ser
pesimista pero de verdad creo que lo he
visto de este lado del mundo también la
integración para efectos energéticos
siempre ofrece muchísimas resistencias
por parte de los diferentes gobiernos
que además hay que recordar todos los
gobiernos del mundo tienen una agenda de
corto plazo y eso hace mucho más
complicada a thomas jones y también los
intereses que puede haber del
empresariado de cada uno de los países
jorge regreso con usted para preguntarle
en la visión que tenemos ahorita de
europa es que están en la primavera está
pasando el tiempo frío el verano está a
la vuelta de la esquina y tal vez no
necesiten tanto suministro de gas pero
en unos pocos meses el invierno va a
regresar la nieve va a regresar y el
norte de europa estará otra vez con
temperaturas bajo cero que puede hacer
europa en estos meses que tiene digamos
de gracia de cara al invierno del 2022
2023 para suministrar gas a sus
ciudadanos almacenar hacer compras por
adelantado y como se puede manejar esta
situación y tomando en cuenta que quiere
desprenderse de rusia precisamente y
también pedirle a los ciudadanos de un
propio programa de conservación no el
gas natural representa el 20 por ciento
de la generación eléctrica en europa los
renovables 24 el sector o la energía
nuclear un 22 17 por ciento la
hidroeléctrica y el carbón un 15 por
ciento así que europa ya está
diversificada desde el punto de vista
total común en las diferentes áreas
van a tener que regresar a ciertas
plantas de carbón que van a tener que
reactivar también los reguladores están
viendo ahora reactivar algunas de las
plantas nucleares que se habían cerrado
pero la diversidad de europa desde el
punto de vista de las diferentes fuentes
de energía para el sector eléctrico ella
existe por cierto estoy de acuerdo con
los zanetti yo creo que la unión europea
en común en total no va a tomar una
decisión de cerrar el grifo ruso tu
puedes ver algunos países que lo hagan
pero no en su totalidad ese es un riesgo
muy grande para ellos repito otra vez me
comentaron al principio alemania tiene
mucho miedo de una recesión que vendría
a través de altos precios del petróleo
de los combustibles
esta guerra le va a costar a europa y no
solamente creen que le va a costar a
rusia le va a costar a ucrania así que
los los cofres de los estados europeos
quizás no van a estar tan llenos
para poder construir todo este nuevo
sistema de energía que europa va a
necesitar
por ejemplo sigo con usted que otros
países dejando de lado los temas
políticos porque se mezclan en este tipo
de situaciones pueden entrar a
diversificar ese mercado se me viene de
pronto a la cabeza por ejemplo e irán
que pueda suministrar un poco más de gas
a través de azerbaiyán oa través de
turquía no sé si türkmenistán pueda
llevarles gas hasta el centro de europa
y otros países del norte de áfrica libia
argelia puede dar un poco más
o libia podría entrar en la jugada como
como ve usted esos posibles mercados si
argelia no tiene capacidad adicional de
aumentar su producción libia como tú
bien sabe tiene ahora mismo un conflicto
interno que le va a ser muy muy difícil
no puede su militar crudo por ejemplo
tienen dificultades algunos los países
de los caucásicos quizás
e irán
una vez más ese es otro problema que los
el grupo de 5 europa está tratando de
ver si pueden reactivar el acuerdo
nuclear con irán yo creo que por ejemplo
en áfrica occidental- angola y nigeria
son exportadores de gas natural natural
licuado y australia australia tiene gran
capacidad de gran futuro para ser
exportadores qatar y yo creo que ya
están más o menos limitados pero
nosotros no vemos la producción de qatar
con ese potencial así que sí yo creo que
y también entonces claro los eeuu los
eeuu tienen una gran capacidad de
aumentar su producción de gas natural
principalmente de esquisto a través de
la fracturación hidráulica tenemos las
líneas de transmisión de los campos aquí
en texas hacia el golfo de méxico así
que yo creo muy importante suministrador
van a ser también los eeuu claro entra
en esta ecuación por supuesto eeuu jorge
rosa net y ya me quedan pocos minutos
para finalizar el programa y quiero
preguntarles
esta situación esta coyuntura
internacional en la que vemos a europa
que ejemplo nos deja a los
latinoamericanos que vemos este tema
como algo muy lejano algo que no nos
molesta que tenemos garantizado nuestro
suministro de gas y de petróleo gracias
a las reservas que tenemos sacar nuestro
territorio en sudamérica en
centroamérica pero como ven ustedes el
ejemplo que nos pueda dejar en un futuro
podemos estar en lo mismo rosa net y
mejor que mencionaba hace un momento
esta guerra va a afectar a toda europa
está claro que esta guerra nos está
afectando a todo el mundo y nos va a
afectar a todo el mundo que ejemplo
podemos tener vamos sin duda que la
dependencia la adicción que como planeta
desarrollamos hacia los hidrocarburos no
se está cobrando la factura y tenemos
que aprender y que encontrar la mejor
vía para para digamos para irla soltando
a efectos de evitar el calentamiento
global
yo creo también sin embargo que una
lesión podría ser la importancia del
desarrollo de regiones en específico yo
tengo muchísima esperanza en la región
américa del norte porque resulta mucho
más fácil creo yo para un país para
países latinoamericanos digamos en algún
tipo de organización regional para
efectos de mantener las cadenas de
suministro lo más cortas posible
incluyendo por supuesto la energía
y jorge su opinión la lección que nos
deja en la región américa latina' este
tipo de coyunturas no como rosa net y
dijo yo creo que el ejemplo muy
importante es ver lo que méxico canadá y
eeuu el tipo de relación que hemos
tenido en energía por los últimos 20 30
años siga el grupo de países
latinoamericanos que también pueden
tener ese tipo de relación pero por
favor no nos olvidemos de aquella
venezuela del 2003 cuando se iba a hacer
o fabricar el gran gasoducto américa del
sur que iba a ir hasta argentina
argentina tiene un gran potencial
brasil tiene un gran potencial brasil
hoy es el mayor productor de petróleo
crudo en toda américa latina de con más
de 3 millones de barriles diarios que
nunca lo que nos pensados así que se
aprecia esos acuerdos regionales pueden
existir pero una vez más por favor
tenemos que ser realistas tenemos que
reconocer que siempre tenemos que tener
diferentes opciones porque no una buena
estrategia de poner una vez más
weborama canatlán diversificación
energética es muy importante a largo
plazo es que es paradójico que europa
tenga que hacer esta diversificación a
rápida velocidad no por el daño
ambiental que estamos presenciando en el
planeta sino por una coyuntura política
y militar que está sucediendo en el este
de ucrania y bueno en el este de europa
me quedan ya pocos segundos para la
conclusión ro zanetti que va a suceder
que va a pasar con europa que va a pasar
con rusia que va a pasar con el
presidente putin y ese as bajo la manga
que tenía siempre que era el suministro
de gas rápidamente mira yo lo lo único
que tengo muy claro es que la
volatilidad va a ser el nombre del juego
por los siguientes meses y después de
que haya algún tipo de definición
digamos en términos específicos sobre la
invasión también tengo muy claro que lo
que sigue es una serie de tomas de
decisiones a nivel de los diferentes
regiones a efectos
de bajar la dependencia de cadenas
lejanas
que van a cambiar la vida y jorge su
conclusión
alguien tiene que pagar por la
reconstrucción de ucrania no sé de qué
bolsillo va a salir los miles de miles
de millones de dólares que va a tomar la
reconstrucción de ese país pero alguien
tiene que pagar
importante es la conclusión de jorge y
rosa net y nuestros invitados del día de
hoy en el debate para hablar sobre este
tema las opciones energéticas que tiene
la unión europea de cara a esa decisión
de cortar por completo el suministro de
gas y de carbón como lo han anunciado
recientemente
procedente de rusia ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y todas
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales a jorge a rózsa net y les
agradezco haber estado con nosotros y
ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía
pueden seguir con la programación de
france 24
[Música]